[Musique]
cette agression contre la nature se
perpétue au d'une chose la plus haute
montagne de par la télévision ya planté
son chapiteau et les immeubles haut
jaillit du sol
mais la banlieue champêtre s'accrochent
encore à quelques nombre de ter ultime
refuge du plaisir de vivre
[Musique]
et puis voici belleville un des derniers
villages du grand paris en 1830 tout un
peu plus joyeux de maraîchers et de
vignerons accueillent est ici les
parisiens souffrent déjà du mal de la
ville les échos de la rire se sont
éteints mais entre les murs lézardés des
maisons des amoureux de la nature
cultive encore obstinément de charmont
petit jardin
un
modeste potager près d'une voie ferrée à
ménilmontant des employés des chemins de
fer perpétue se réconfortant miracle
un coin de banlieue n'ont pas du tout la
placera et danube
ce fut d'abord une carrière de pierres
nommé carrière d'amérique puis un marché
aux chevaux
aujourd'hui c'est encore un refuge pour
ceux qui veulent se donner l'illusion de
fuir la grandville
ma
c'est ici qu'est né au coeur de
belleville celle qui savait si bien
faire battre le coeur de paris
un escalier tahoua
une vieille mansarde
et me voilà chez moi
un lit qui secondaire une table devient
gua
une lampe à pétrole
et moi
chez moi
[Musique]
et que mon frère est partout malheureux
écarte les rideaux de ma fenêtre
et gérard guy
dieu
de l'autre côté de la rue il ya une
fille
la fille
qui a tout ce qui lui pourrait même le
super plus lente rodez
un autre sommet de paris la colline de
chaillot au siècle passé on y venez
respirer l'air des cimes sophie arnould
lafayette madame d'epinay barras choque
pas et va refaire des cures d'oxygène et
puis voilà qu'un jour de 1720 ab qui fut
l'aumônier de madame de maintenon il
découvre trois source ferrugineuse du
coup pas s'y est lancé et devient la
station thermale à la mode
[Musique]
à deux pas de l'étoile ce paisible
potager n'est pas un jardin ordinaire il
plane à quelque 50 mètres du sol et
abrite sous ses massifs 65 mille mètres
cubes d'eau c'est le château d'eau de la
rue lauriston qui offre à ses voisins le
privilège d'une permanente évasion de
verdure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quittons l'ancien village de passy pour
se vider auteuil il y a deux siècles les
paysans mais ici leur belle au chant
veaux vaches et cochons ont déserté le
16e arrondissement
[Musique]
les canards plat paris ce n'est pas si
banal
en 1847 un célèbre aliénistes moteur
blanche il installa sa clinique il avait
turin pensionnaire de qualité le cher
gérard de nerval le poète en effet avait
dû faire un séjour chez le médecin à la
suite d'une certaine promenade au palais
royal où il tenait en laisse à homards
vivants
[Musique]
oh
ces maisons de campagne parisienne ces
jardins miniaturisés qui semble refléter
la nostalgie des années folles ont un
créateur commun l'architecte mallet
stevens
[Musique]
à
non vous n'êtes pas au coeur de la
savane brésilienne
ce perroquet habite rue raynouard c'est
un parisien authentique tout comme cette
tortue d'ailleurs quant à l'exotisme
tropicale qui vous est offert il n'est
pas baigné par le fleuve d amazon mais
plus simplement par la scène
ce spectacle c'est celui où balzac avait
sous les yeux lorsqu'il habitait la
maison voisine
combien de personnages de la comédie
humaine sont nées de la contemplation de
s'étendre bissau
dans un joli château qui s'appelle le
château de passy vivait jadis une belle
princesse la princesse de lamballe sa
promenade l'amener souvent dans ses
allées fleuries d'elle il ne reste plus
qu'un fantôme gracieux et du parc du
château quelques morceaux de jardin qui
suffisent à dépayser le promeneur
[Musique]
au milieu de son univers de béton il
arrive que le bâtisseur des temps
modernes interrompt parfois sa course
fatale et sème des arbres au milieu des
pierres les immeubles de la rue des
belles feuilles tout près de la place
victor hugo démontre qu'on peut édifier
une cité nouvelle tout en lui donnant
les moyens de respirer il s'élève sur
l'emplacement de l'hippodrome ou 10000
spectateurs s'entassaient au siècle
dernier pour admirer la parade du plus
vaste cirque parisien
[Musique]
laissons le rythme de la ville reprendre
ses droits juste le temps de traverser
paris le lion de belfort
le faubourg saint-jacques
l'hôpital cochin
[Musique]
et maintenant regardez bien ce bel hôtel
au milieu d'un jardin de province il est
arrivé la plus étonnante des aventures
il a déménagé
[Musique]
oui vous avez parfaitement encore vu
l'hôtel de massa a changé de quartier en
1928 il s'élevait encore rue la boétie à
deux pas des champs elysées meta lequel
il gênait fort des promoteurs
immobiliers qui lâche terre pour lui
substituer un immeuble moderne mais le
ministre de l'instruction publique de
l'époque qui s'appelait edouard herriot
n'accepta pas cet holocauste et pierre
par pierre l'hôtel de massa furent
édifiés sur cet emplacement où ses
frondaisons abrite désormais la société
des gens de lettres
ici ce sont des dominicains qui font
vivre un beau jardin rue des tanneries
sous laquelle coule la bièvre grâce à ce
jardin les habitants du quartier peuvent
durant quelques instants oubliez les
fumées de la ville et respirait comme à
la campagne les moines ont même suspendu
un jardin sur le toit de leur couvre
ce sont les mêmes rêves de verdure les
mêmes besoins de nature qui ont permis
qu'on crée un espace vert entre ciel et
terre au 26e étage d'une tour
rue de la glacière
[Musique]
puisse ce salutaire exemple être suivi
par tous les bâtisseurs de notre cité
édifié il y a un siècle la cité fleuret
abrita des générations d'artistes
entre autres gauguin modigliani rodin
bourdelle mayol cet îlot de quiétude de
l'est fatalement aiguiser l'appétit des
spéculateurs mais les indigènes veiller
sur leur village et la cité fleurie fut
sauvée
notre promenade aujourd'hui s'achèvera
dans ce grand jardin qui abrite
l'institution de sourds muets saint
louis avant de partir pour la croisade
va fonder receipts la commanderie saint
jacques diop à plus tard la commanderie
de vins d'abbayes saint-magloire puis le
séminaire des prêtres de l'oratoire une
parmi leurs élèves les oratoriens avait
un jeune garçon fort distraits qui ne
s'intéressait qu'aux jardins il est vrai
qu'il se nommait gens de fontaine
de nos jours les élèves de l'institution
retrouve les pas du grand fabuliste et
au gré de leurs désirs font pousser ici
des fleurs des fruits ou même des
légumes
ainsi vous l'avez vu grâce à une poignée
d'aventuriers la nature paris vous
réserve encore des joies scène et
champêtre
si chacun prenait conscience du rôle
indispensable de la nature dans la ville
il ne serait pas toujours nécessaire de
prendre sa voiture pour aller la
chercher au loin
[Musique]